lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
cerciorarme de que fácilmente podemos
manejar expresiones algebraicas que
incluyen fracciones empecemos con un
ejemplo sencillo supongamos que tenemos
sobre ve más
sobre de si queremos sumar estas dos
fracciones para tener una sola fracción
cómo hacemos eso bien para empezar
necesitamos encontrar un común
denominador entre b y d no conocemos b
no conocemos de pero sabemos que el
producto debe por d es un múltiplo de
ambos
así es que podemos escribir esto como
dos fracciones que tienen común
denominador b de más algo sobre b de
déjame usar colores para distinguir así
es que a sobre b es lo mismo a que sobre
b de sí para obtener bebé multiplique el
denominador por d vamos a multiplicar
también el numerador por d de esa manera
la expresión no se altera pues estamos
multiplicando la x de sobre d
esto va a ser por d sobre b por de
observa que si divido el numerador y el
denominador entre de regreso a a entre b
y ahora veamos la segunda fracción se
sobre d para ir de d
a vd multiplicamos por d así que si
multiplique el denominador por d para no
alterar el valor de la fracción tengo
que multiplicar el numerador también por
d así es que también el numerador lo
multiplicamos por b por lo cual va a ser
b c tenemos entonces b c sobre b de que
es lo mismo que se sobre de lo que tengo
aquí en magenta esta fracción es
equivalente a esta fracción simplemente
la multiplique por d sobre de que es 1
suponiendo que es distinto de 0 también
aquí hemos multiplicado se sobre d por 1
que es lo mismo que ve sobre b
suponiendo que b es distinto de 0 así es
que esta fracción y esta fracción son
equivalentes y para que nos tomamos
todas estas molestias bien ahora las
fracciones ya tienen un común
denominador por lo cual ya podemos
sumarlas así es que esto es igual a el
común denominador vd es el denominador
común ambas fracciones y que pasa en el
numerador podemos sumar los numeradores
como si fueran simples números como si
no estuvieran en una fracción pues
tienen el mismo denominador
así es que esto es igual a d
+ b c
todo eso dividido entre vd